Kingfisher tip Combs and plates have  been specifically designed and tested  for the use of Kingfisher Flex Duo Prime  Apex and Presto instruments they are  manufactured from polypropylene which  means that these are ideal for magnetic  particle processing and ensures  excellent recovery of magnetic beads due  to their low binding affinity for  biomolecules you should use the depot  Kingfisher plate depending on which  instrument you use as well as how much  solution you need to test your  application we also have the shallow  Kingfisher well played to use for  illusion Kingfisher tip Combs are used  to protect the magnetic rods from  contamination